[Music]
hey everyone welcome to other
installments of Harry Potter theory in
this video star wars theories prepared a
fanfiction for you guys the first of
many on the channel so sit back relax
and enjoy hello everyone and welcome to
the first fanfiction on Harry Potter
theory in today's fanfiction we're gonna
change the events of the infamous night
that Dumbledore died after grabbing the
Horcrux from the cave Dumbledore
operated with Harry to the top spire of
Hogwarts where he met his untimely yet
chosen death by Snape Dumbledore had
made Snape promise to kill him when the
time was right when he asked for it he
knew that he was dying anyways after the
curse that had left him weakened he took
the heroic way out and used his
inevitable death to serve a larger
purpose which was to fool Voldemort and
his followers that Snape was indeed one
of them to be trusted
allowing Snape to be the Spy that Albus
wanted too much of Snape's dismay he was
obligated to perform the killing curse
that night to his mentor and his friend
during the scene you can see the
hesitation and Snape's eyes and face and
you just know that he really doesn't
want to do it
it wasn't until Dumbledore asked twice
by saying please to Severus that the
deed was finally done and the headmaster
was nothing more but a corpse falling
off the Tower of Hogwarts only to leave
the Death Eaters in celebration Snape
was one of them now entirely trusted and
able to spy on the Dark Lord for the
greater good of the world but what if
that night atop the spire Snape didn't
go through with his vow what if he
instead fired the curse at one of the
Death Eaters and Dumbledore took his
wand from the ground after having let
Malfoy disarm him earlier and started to
fire back this would have changed
everything
Dumbledore and Snape would have teamed
up against everyone
dodging blocking and casting spells
towards all those before them
Malfoy would most likely be spared and
simply disarmed or frozen
possibly Petrificus Totalus to just keep
him unharmed but also so he may do no
harm against his better judgment
Dumbledore albeit now severely weak from
the curse and the events of the cave
was still a formidable opponent for all
the death eaters who were arrogant as
always yet this time slapped with real
fear none was more powerful than
Voldemort unless of course
Dumbledore were still alive and very
much alive he still was as he fired a
curse at Bellatrix causing her to meet
the same fate Dumbledore did in the
Canon timeline as she tumbled off the
towers edge to her death the others
scattered about in fear trying to take
cover from the barrage of attacks from
the two immensely powerful wizards they
were trapped
no one can operate in or out of Hogwarts
unless of course you're Dumbledore
himself and at being him has its
advantages Harry sees Corbin Yaxley
about to fire the Cruciatus curse at
Snape when he runs up the stairs and
puts himself in front of Snape and
shouts
Sectumsempra casting Yaxley backwards
with immense force has blood splattered
the walls falling face-first into the
floorboards dying Snape looked at Harry
and raised a brow Harry Snape and
Dumbledore were unstoppable against the
Death Eaters they soon dwindled the
numbers down and killed them all
not without sustaining major injuries
themselves of course
Severus you fool do you know what you
have just done are you all right
couldn't kill you you've promised me you
would do as I say you've put us all in
more danger than you know
mad boy said Harry Draco was starting to
move slowly as the two professor decided
it would be best to remove his memory of
the recent events so they targeted what
had happened and used obliviate to rid
his mind of the recent events altering
his memory so that he were still in his
dorm room fast asleep the events to come
next would be entirely different from
the events of the seventh book as
Dumbledore would still be alive and
working with Snape they would destroy
the locket from the cave which would
inevitably make Voldemort more aware of
his imminent mortality and what Hogwarts
is doing to kill him after questioning
Malfoy Voldemort would finally realize
that the boy's mind was wiped and he'd
know exactly what had happened that
night he would try to have sever's
killed for his betrayal after coming to
the conclusion that Dumbledore and Snape
killed his Death Eaters who were
supposed to go with Malfoy
night the ending would turn much more
favorable for our heroes in the sense
that Hogwarts would be so much more
protected with just Snape and Dumbledore
fighting against Voldemort and all the
evil he brings to the castle that said
it can go two ways
so Harry Ron and Hermione wouldn't be on
an Easter egg hunt for how to destroy
the locket as Dumbledore would probably
know how to do it relatively quickly the
Horcruxes would almost all but be
destroyed save for maybe one or two and
in the event they waited for Voldemort
to storm the castle things would be much
different indeed Ron would still have
both of his brothers George and Fred
would be alive and quite unscathed the
casualties of the students would be
reduced more than half and I could see
Dumbledore and Snape single handedly
taking out the majority of the threats
coming to the castle along with the
other professors of course but they
would be the a-team
I could see Albus fighting Voldemort
possibly getting thwarted aside for
maybe dramatic effect as JK Rowling
could write and a blast of Avada Kedavra
could be sent towards Harry where Snape
would jump in front of it sacrificing
himself for Lily's son and saving him
this would be a very poetic sacrifice
and it would kind of tie Snape's love
for Lily in one moment it's something I
could see Snape doing
I always felt Snape's death was just
very uneventful for someone as prominent
in the books and films as he was he
deserved a better death but it just goes
to show how much of a cold bastard
Voldemort really was at the flick of a
switch or wand we could say here he
would have his right-hand man killed so
quickly just so that he would in his
mind falsely have full use of the Elder
Wand Harry could then fight Voldemort
and with Neville killing Nagini at the
last moment or at the right moment in a
locked duel of magic I think Harry could
have killed Voldemort the same way that
we got it in the film and books as
Dumbledore somewhat consciously looked
on in the distance from his great fall
from Voldemort's attack everything would
be over Malfoy would run away with his
parents the Death Eaters would be no
more everyone would pay the respects for
Severus and have funeral in his honor
I could see Albus wanting to carry out
other Advent
from this point on he knew that his time
was limited with the curse that was
enveloping his whole body so he would
appoint Minerva McGonagall as headmaster
dan ding would end the same for Harry
Ron and Hermione most likely as they
would carry on in the same way that they
do in the film however you can always
wonder that maybe Harry would have
joined Albus in possibly finding a cure
somewhere in the world and all the
little adventures that they'd get up to
that would have been a really
interesting series that JK Rowling could
have made maybe I can create fan
fictions on what if Harry and Albus did
go on these adventures I think that
would be really fun thanks for watching
have an awesome rest every day and until
the next video remember it is not our
abilities that show us who we truly are
it is our choices
[Music]